[Music]
he shot and killed
horrifically incomprehensibly
14
students
and killed a teacher
we begin tonight with breaking news at
least 14 children one teacher dead after
a shooting at an elementary school in
the small texas town of yuvaldi
that town is about 85 miles west of san
antonio this happened 11 30 texas time
that school home to second third and
fourth grade students authorities have
spent the afternoon and early evening
notifying families there well the
governor of texas greg abbott saying the
suspected shooter was 18 years old and
was believed to be killed by responding
officers the governor said two police
officers were shot neither had serious
injuries and he also said the suspect
may have shot his grandmother this
morning
it is being reported
that the subject
shot his grandmother right before he
went into the school
and there is i have no further
information about the connection between
those two shootings
and the subject is reported to be a
student to have been a student at
u-valley high school
and is a u.s citizen
the shooter has been identified as
18-year-old salvador ramos of uvalde as
you just heard governor abbott say he is
a u.s citizen well president biden has
ordered all flags to be flown at half
staff and we are expecting him to speak
at around 5 15 tonight las vegas mayor
carolyn goodman responding this
afternoon tweeting quote we can't
imagine the pain the families in uvalde
texas are experiencing the loss of these
innocent lives is beyond comprehension
we are horrified and may their souls
rest in peace
from governor steve sisilak he says
quote our hearts are broken again kathy
and i are sending our love and our
prayers to the uvalde community in texas
in the aftermath of this horrific
shooting
as we mentioned the president of the
united states has been briefed on the
shooting and will be addressing the
nation in about an hour's time we will
carry that live right here on 8 news now